avez-vous déjà été avant non jamais
la dernière relation a duré combien d'
années clou de girofle préférence sexuelle femmes des
enfants non et le chien ouais c'est mon
frère il était ici il y a quelques
années mais il n'a pas réussi
bonjour 44 jours restants  le petit-déjeuner est
servi
comme vous le comprenez d'après l'expérience de votre frère
si vous ne tombez pas sur
quelqu'un d'autre pendant votre séjour ici, vous vous
transformerez en animal voudriez-vous
danser de
manière à vous engager
aujourd'hui vous êtes devenu ici c'est plus rapide qu'un
autre jour c'est bien s'il vous plaît  juste un
peu plus
bonjour tout le monde ma
caractéristique déterminante est que j'ai un très
beau sourire nous devons être totalement
synchronisés cinq quatre trois deux avez-
vous pensé à quel animal vous aimeriez
être si vous vous retrouvez seul oui un homard un
homard est  un excellent choix je ne peux pas
aller beaucoup plus vite ce pantalon est trop
serré je suis désolé